when we begin to normalize the signal
will be that things are more normal well
if we get a rate move now does that have
any kind of negative impact on the
economy that you are concerned about
well you can never say never there are
always unintended consequences but the
way I think about it is we're
calibrating the interest rate level to
where the economy is and what the
outlook for the economy is and and if we
make that calculation pretty close to
correct we should not see unintended
consequences if that calibration is made
what would it be with 25 basis points be
appropriate for an economy like this or
should you really be higher but you're
constrained by what you can do I think
we start with 25 basis points I think
that's pretty obvious and and the
committee has communicated several times
that the expectation is the path of
interest rate rises going forward would
be very gradual well the markets seem to
have a different view of the path why
haven't they come together well there
are some technical factors at work you
know we communicate our sense of the
path through the summary of economic
projections that comes out every quarter
and the question we're answering is
assuming appropriate monetary policy
what should be the path that's sort of a
circular kind of assumption in a way and
the markets are weighing the
probabilities of an interest rate rise
in one at one time or another and and in
effect placing their bets on the
probabilities it's not surprising that
those are different I think most recent
data i saw was about a fifty percent
probability so it's fifty-fifty around
the next meeting that seems to me to be
given the current circumstances a
reasonable assessment of the situation
well you have to publish an assessment
at least it you have to turn one in at
the next meeting what's your forecast
for growth the rest of this year it is
2016 I think we'll see a moderate pace
of growth the second quarter we saw
actually the most recent estimate was
three-point-seven percent and that's a
rather strong rebound from the week
first quarter I expect the third quarter
to be less than that therefore the a
slowing relative to the second quarter I
look over the year I think the run rate
so to speak is probably between two and
a half and three percent something in
that range I think that's a reasonable
rate of growth for for this year last
question about 30 seconds if you decide
not to raise rates in September would
you vote to put a press conference in
place to give yourself the optionality
in the future well that's the that's the
chairs decision I think a press
conference can be called on relatively
short notice you'll show up won't you
I'll be there what if I call I probably
know why they're calling that's the
class oh so I think October's is a live
meeting it's in play the difference
being a simply a scheduled press
conference versus one that's called so
clearly I think we want at the timing of
liftoff to have the chair to have the
opportunity to explain the committee's
views and to really give some context to
the decision and so I don't think
there's a big difference between calling
a press conference and one that's
scheduled